one of my favorite things about the show
is like people get married a lot on the
show and every person at the hospital
leaves their job to attend said wedding
and so i just imagine like someone being
like oh my god there was a car accident
there's so much blood and like the
chances there's just a janitor there
being like sorry they're at a wedding
like hope you feel better
the grey's anatomy death that i remember
most was um
when george died i think i was watching
around this time or maybe he died
shortly after i stopped watching but i
seem to recall seeing that there was a
guy he like got hit by a bus
and he was like all lumpy and bandaged
up and he couldn't talk
and then he died
and i seem to recall that there were
rumors that it was played by a different
actor but i couldn't find confirmation
of this nina can you confirm or deny
this i'd i never heard that that's
actually okay
i must have dreamed this
mick dreamed it
it's super possible because what happens
is this guy gets
the character is like going to enlist in
the army so all his friends are going to
stage an intervention and he never shows
up because he's laying in a hospital bed
um all like unrecognizably bloodied from
saving a woman by jumping in front of a
bus and the only reason they figure out
it's him is because he his nickname as a
surgical intern was double07
because he had license to kill
and he's
like sprawls double yeah yeah and he
scrolls double of seven into someone's
hand yeah yeah yeah yeah he was
definitely not the doctor that you
wanted by your bedside i'm really so
i'm really sorry if tr knight is
watching this because i really like this
character um
yeah but no so he uh he like scrolls
double 07 into meredith's palm and she's
like it's george yeah and then they try
to save him and then they don't yeah but
he does i don't know if it is a
different i mean it's very possible just
a body double or something but he shows
up at the very end of the episode in
like a dream sequence that makes it
clear he's dying so it it could be
tierra tr night and it could not be i
actually don't know so what i take issue
with here right is that he's leaving the
show because he had issues with
the show runner at that time uh shonda
rhimes yeah um
he'd gotten into a conflict with one of
the other actors you know totally
behind the scenes drama stuff and you
know who would listen to the show before
that
long before that yeah things were going
on and it was time it was time to go so
they write the character out by saying
he's going to join the army
and then he gets hit by a bus anyway
yeah
yeah
which is just one of those things where
are you saying that was overkill
kill or overkill it's just kind of
literally like he was already like you
already had an exit lined up for this
character he was already already being
written out of the show
and then he gets hit by a bus i think
for grey's anatomy the problem is it's
been going on so long that i think
sometimes actors prefer to die on the
show because like every interview sandra
oh does they're like so when are you
gonna go back to and she's like i'm not
like i've done so much other stuff since
then please watch killing eve please
watch the chair stop asking me she just
left and she left on good terms she was
just like i
want to go do other stuff but like they
did not kill her character and so every
interview she does people are just like
are you that's what i was gonna do
yeah okay so yeah so so they do it kind
of as an insurance policy against i
think some actors are probably like yeah
just give me like a crazy death um so
that i don't have to put the scrubs back
on
so you think this was tr night's idea
i can only make guesses but maybe i mean
it's it's an insane
it's also like this is a show that loves
uh
insane twists and really over the top
definitely not possible medical problems
and this is a perfect marriage of those
two things so i don't maybe they just
couldn't resist how often does the
insurance policy pay out on that how
often
do you mean on the doctors dying at this
hospital because doctors die at a much
higher rate than the patients do oh no
no i'm not i'm sure that that's true
that's yeah that's high drama but like
no i mean like
how often does it work that an actor
gets killed on the show and then never
comes back because my understanding is
dying on grey's anatomy not a death
sentence like you you do come back for
like a bunch of dream sequences and and
fantasy
whatnots right that was a pandemic thing
that we won't even talk about okay
interesting yeah i'm coming to you for
advice
that was a pandemic era dream sequence
vibe that um although i guess you're
right like jeffrey dean morgan came back
in one of the show's worst plot lines so
that character died right he had a
stroke or something he got a heart
transplant and then had a stroke
okay naturally and so how did he come
back as his twin brother or
no he came back as a hallucination of
katherine heigl's character uh to tell
her she had cancer
explaining it and he was extremely trust
with your medical history he was an
oncologist
yeah he was
he was an oncology ghost and there was a
lot of um
like he was her fiance so there were a
lot of scenes where like the two finally
got together which i think they wanted
fans to like but we were all like he's
dead this is weird who's she talking to
like it's just it's it's baffling so
gotcha
i don't know what the rules are really
on grey's anatomy ghosts per se but uh
you know i think
i think it really depends on the actor
and their relationship with the show i'm
curious as to what tom's weirdest death
is i'm also curious
you guys
i've been waiting weeks for you to ask
me that i'm excited
i'm not terribly familiar with grey's
anatomy but like brian i i also have
known women and they
way to generalize bud
i'm speaking to my own specific opinion
uh
experience
generally grey's anatomy is what comes
on like right around the time that
it doesn't matter
i had to i had to get some outside help
with this uh i watched my first couple
of episodes of grey's anatomy ever to
learn about this
um
i have paid attention but i took a bunch
of notes
on the stuff that i did
it's from a two-parter from season two
called meredith gray and the gnarly
ballad of bazooka joe
uh
parts one and two it gets an a plus for
title and nina i'm kind of counting on
you to to help like correct me if i'm
mistaken about some stuff on this okay
i'm more than happy to help with uh the
episode that definitely is called that
and not a totally different thing
absolutely right
no it's called it's the end of the world
as we know it
in space if you say so nina i just
watched it so i feel pretty confident
about this
all right fair enough
you know which you know which death i'm
talking about though right yes
okay unless you think a different
character died in which case i can't
help you
so meredith gray at the beginning of the
episode she has superpowers uh she says
that she can like tell when she's gonna
die and it's gonna happen today and
their friends are like you gotta go to
do surgery and she says and this is
actually i wrote this part down she says
uh i don't care about surgeries and she
goes back to bed
this episode was nominated for an emmy
for writing
so was the game of thrones finale
there's my only rebuttal
it's a good rebuttal that's a great
thank you
thank you great rebuttal
thanks go on tom
a solid point
uh okay so she goes to work anyway uh
she she tells dr patrick dempsey that
she can see the future and he's like
yeah i've also stared into eternity and
then they share a moment and uh
dr catherine heigl says that she's not
gonna sleep with dr another guy
and she says that in front of all of her
co-workers she's like i'm never gonna
sleep with you dr another guy and he's
like please and she's like nah and then
uh boss doctor comes in and she has a
baby and that's when the episode lay
really starts this is also when the lady
that i've been seeing starts to get mad
at me for talking through the whole
episode so an ambulance
pulls up to the hospital and there's a
woman screaming in the back and it's
very unclear whether she has been
screaming the whole time that she was in
the ambulance or if she just like showed
up and saw doctors and she was scared of
them uh there's a guy inside of the
ambulance who has
a chest wound a grievous chest wound and
christina ricci is the ambulance lady
that's correct
that's they're called emts but
that you don't have to watch grey's
anatomy to know you you are a human who
probably should know what an emt is
dropping the the grey's anatomy lore on
you yeah
a mythical creature called an emt
we don't all read the grey's anatomy
wiki obsessively and know what they're
called nina yeah i'm not a huge fan
[Laughter]
so an emt is inside uh and she's playing
the ambulance lady and she
is
so it's christina ricci and this is this
part's really really funny she she's
christina reaching into a guy's chest
because he
because he has a big sucking chest wound
and then they do the opening theme song
which i think we all know the opening
theme song grey's anatomy i don't even
need to bring that up
um please don't make me sing
so the christina the christina ricci guy
like he's he's unconscious and his
wife's screaming all the time and when
she finally stops screaming 17 minutes
later it's 17 minutes of the episode she
stops screaming they figure out that
what actually what happened to the
unconscious guy
is that he
shot himself with a bazooka
that's correct so this guy built a
bazooka it didn't work so he elmer
flooded and just like climbed out in
front of it and stared down the barrel
and accidentally shot himself in the
chest with the bazooka that's correct
that's actually correct that happened
thank you very much because i actually i
do feel like i need somebody to tell me
that i didn't just eat a bunch of spicy
food and come up with this story on my
own because around this point it's part
of a civil war reenactment or something
no not civil war like world war ii
the civil war with bazookas
they're trending numbers have been down
across the board at civil war
reenactments ever since everybody
realized that the whole good guy bad guy
thing was pretty black and white
everyone's got a [ __ ]
and mine is the civil war
and weaponry
and weaponry
at least i know what happens in this
episode
anyway so we find out that the guy shot
himself with a bazooka and that's why
he's sick and at this point i'm writing
on my tablet and i break my
stylus because i'm writing so hard and
i'm so angry about it so i had to switch
over to my notepad
oh boy
so then
so
he's got an unexploded round in his
chest he's got an unexploded brown in
his chest christina ricci has to keep
her hand inside of his chest or it'll
blow up maybe we don't know
so they bring in the bomb squad and the
bomb squad is being led by coach carter
from friday night lights his name's
coach taylor
coach taylor that's his name they got
coach taylor from friday night lights
and he's on can't even know friday night
lights too is that so much to ask
how many shows do you want me to watch
so he comes in and he's all like bright
eyes bazooka tummies can't lose and then
they
the best part of this two-part episode
is when the bomb squad guy looks at the
x-ray of the guy's chest with the
bazooka around inside of it and it's
it's like the size of a toaster and it
jus
it's just it's taking up his entire
torso
and he and the head of surgery
stare at this x-ray and i swear to god
the the
the bomb squad guy goes
when the hell are people gonna learn
implying that this is not the first time
that somebody shot themselves with a
bazooka right like
a homie he's an old hand at this yeah
yeah right
and then the the the doctor guy that
he's standing next to says maybe it's
not as bad as it looks and again
this show got an emmy nomination for
writing and i can't stop laughing
i really don't think either
meredith gray uh winds up sticking her
hand into the guy's chest so that
christina ricci can run away uh sorry so
that the emt can run away
and then uh that's the end of part one
and then at the beginning of part two uh
catherine heigl has sex with that guy
that she said she wouldn't have sex with
i get into a fight with the girl that
i've been seeing she leaves i start to
get drunk
uh
meredith gray winds up meeting up with
uh patrick dempsey doctor and then
patrick dempsey doctor turns into my dad
and he starts shouting uh about how
disappointed he is in me
and then i realized that i fell asleep
and when i wake up
the coach from friday night lights
explodes
does he really he actually explodes he
does explode
15.9 million people watch this episode
that's all
that's the second season
if i'm not mistaken it was a super bowl
episode
you're absolutely right it was i did
some reading
well yeah that does sound like it works
a pretty wild death
nina
why don't you tell us about yours
okay
um i mean i feel like
i feel like a huge goober being like i
like gru's anatomy after all of this
preample
um i like grace
anatomy feel free to sue me but don't
actually because i can't afford a lawyer
i mean it's one of the most popular
shows on television so clearly it's not
bad to like grey's anatomy right um but
i just know we're watching this clicked
on it because it has grey's anatomy in
this i just am aware of this
in this setting i know exactly how alone
i am and that and i just i just need to
sit with that knowledge
um there's one episode of this show
actually there are two episodes i won't
uh ever watch when i re-watch this show
one is one where uh it turns into a
musical and they just sing pop songs
over the whole thing and it's terrible
it's so bad it's so bad they call it
glee's anatomy or did they just do that
they left that one and they left that
one it was too low hanging fruit they
couldn't take it
the other one i won't watch partly
because this is just a phobia that i
actually have in my life
is uh
there is one where
every major doctor from the hospital
because they always allow them to do
like the same thing at the same time one
of my favorite things about the show is
like people get married a lot on the
show and every person at the hospital
leaves their job to attend said wedding
and so i just imagine like someone being
like oh my god there was a car accident
there's so much blood and like
there's just a janitor there being like
sorry they're at a wedding like hope you
feel better
so
they always have like everyone in the
same place at the same time which to me
feels like a terrible idea it's like you
know how like you don't have the
president the same room as the speaker
of the house most of the time so
there's one where they send every single
attending physician
to on a tiny little plane and it crashes
um and that neatly disposes of two main
characters lexi gray and mark sloane and
also the leg of another character
arizona robins so it's technically two
and a half casualties
the legs contract was up yeah the legs
contract was up um yeah so
and the characters they kill off are a
couple
so it's very like depressing because
like she dies first because she's
totally trapped under the plain rubble
and he's like you're gonna get out we're
gonna have kids and it's gonna be great
and then she dies and then he is like
i'm totally fine and then like he passes
out and they lift up his shirt and his
like intestines fall out um
tom finally looks intrigued by something
yeah um i'm no i am i'm so intrigued by
this show because everything that i can
tell about it is that it's it's
basically like that first transformers
movie the cartoon one where they like
every season they just need to wipe out
the slate and bring in like new toys
and just introduce new grey's anatomy
action figures that everybody's gonna go
out and buy for christmas i have one
more defense and this one actually was a
frustrating death in terms of like you
just wanted something to go better for
this person mandy moore played a part in
the season six finale which is a
two-part episode where a disgruntled
former patient's husband comes to the
hospital with a gun and he kills half
the staff and it's actually like
after the final season of game of
thrones i actually went back and
re-watched that and i was like cool
dramatic tension stakes
that's i remember what these are now and
so mandy moore survives a hospital
shooting like
she's a patient
like awaiting surgery she manages to
like not get shot and then in the next
season she comes back to get her surgery
and she dies in surgery
right
and you're just like why
yeah it's kind of it's it's a cruel it's
a casually cruel show for being like a
network sitcom with a lot of kissing on
it like it's just it's mean it's a mean
show that spends a lot of time hurting
people's feelings um
many people have been like the most
prolific serial killer of our time as
shonda rhimes because all she does is
just murder people with impunity
especially when she's mad at them which
is extremely cool
it's just it's interesting though
because i mean like you know soap operas
are notorious for people you know dying
right back to life secret lost sister
you know right
these these network dramas they're the
same thing they just have better
production values but it also has like
some like some spite baked in like
patrick dempsey was like i want more
time to go race my cars and how does he
die car crash like it's it's so petty
i love it
wouldn't that be great if after they
kill off george by hitting him with a
bus every single character that they
write off is also hit by a bus they're
like he also was hit by a bus trying to
save someone
everyone was hit by a bus
that's a show it could get behind in
seattle there's like an epidemic of
buses just hitting people all the time
like the buses have gone crazy and then
you spin off like the bus whisperer and
someone's got to try to track down this
this bus killer
yeah played by eliza dushku
yes
she's back
she has to go back in time to the bus
depot and her first name is boss
[Laughter]
you're welcome network tv place bus
mulligan
she used to be a bus driver
yes
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe